i didn't do good in school because i  knew my mouth and my brain kind of like  worked in a different way yeah but we  need these doctors we need these nurses  they're not asking you the question what  do you mean what question i'll explain  you knew your mouth and your words and  your things worked a certain way and you  knew the answer was no for you yeah the  people that are gonna be the doctors  that you want they're not rolling up to  you and me and asking if they should go  they're just going it's the in-between  and the in-between was always told it's  a good bet and my point is a lot of  people should go to college okay so  you're not against it completely no i'm  against lack of self-awareness and i'm  against the place we were in for the  last 30 years where everyone should go  lack of choice lack of choice  everyone should go to college was the  absolute cultural rule